então é natal e o que você fez
e aí galera capricho ronaldo gozei natal
git olha que coisa maravilhosa de natal
é tão bom porque as pessoas se por xuxa
e o quê que você vai me dar de natal
inteligente que chega o natal fica
perguntando o que ela vai ganhar porque
tu vai me dar de natal e gente
interesseira só que chega o natal podem
apresentar a pessoa nem família nem
minha amiga aí chega o natal fiquei
inquérito vai me dar de presente uma me
dá vontade de dizer se minha filha
aniversário de jesus nasceu não viu que
completa hoje agenda não é você e eu
quiser o corpo foi feito quatro bottom
up para subir com força de pé jesus
mandou pra você não é papai noel em todo
lugar meu deus a toda hora o papai noel
não é bom isto é um papai noel sempre
que iniciou a falar de volta o papai
noel que esse é um programa tem um papai
noel de prancha de casa de praia e tomar
um suco sem a mesma página foi o papai
noel não tem tempo para tomar uma surra
em praia não ela tem que entregar o
presente e sempre que chega o natal tem
aquela longe e inventa de botar um papai
noel do tamanho de uma pessoa real e uma
panela fica dançando em frente à loja
está me dando uma agulha de bonecos já
mesmo boneco dançando ataque é meu nem
do papai noel dançar no gordão e
taffarel aparece lendo assim pra mim
todo o painel parece ela não quer
parecer é que leandro hassum agora é um
pouco como tanquinho ficar fortinho
bonitinho na nação que ficou maria
bonitinha eu sou a pessoa que sou muito
gordinha às vezes consigo emagrecer
aí chega o natal embora porque tem
comida que só o [ __ ] ao vivo uma
coisa que chama efeito sanfona que você
enche ceca enche seguem x eu tanto
efeito sanfona que eu apelidei de
dorgival dantas foi me leva pra tocar
numa banda que soltou de um acordeão e
falando leva o assunto era gordinho eu
emagreci vida estreou agora dia 24 de
dezembro até que a sorte não separar e
três à falência final que é o filme que
o leandro hassum é protagonista do filme
é tão ligado e assistindo o jogo foi
muito bom até garrafas e para um táxi
para 2 e tem agora três pela no assunto
é camila morgado legal e ilegal e bota
deixar o link do trailer aqui o trailer
é só clicar aqui e mais 13 não se
preocupa que não vai fechar esse vídeo
que não é só vai abrir um tapa depois as
estrelas
fica aqui a assistir o treino e até que
a sorte nos separe 3 com leandro hassum
a falência final e todo natal todas as
lojas coloca aquela musiquinha então é
natal e o que você fez para dizer oh meu
deus me pergunto o que foi que eu tenho
nesse ano não eu sou aquele tipo de
pessoa que o ano passa rápido chega no
final do ano parece que ele para fazer
um lanche não acaba mais eu fico 2015
meu filho acaba pelo amor de deus silva
na luta mas o vento a localização então
é natal que o que você fez ou não fez
nada caso das garrafas posteriormente
tomar um sorvete começa a chegar os
parentes na casa da gente que todo mundo
tem que ir para casa porque os pais não
passar o natal na casa dele vem destruir
remover ou longe que nunca eu me
interesse que a gente que gosta de samba
e pagode of god of war is an act um
primo que você se dá bem só o irmão lá
na [ __ ] casa da [ __ ] que caiu do [ __ ]
nunca vai passar o natal com você nunca
as tinha zumbi chão parece um barril de
petróleo a botar a música aqui pra vocês
meus filhos então é natal lá há aqueles
tiques engraçadão quando cheguei eu
tinha em casa da minha mãe se mantém
esse ano não faz favor por favor me tap
a dia vamos evitar o estresse tap com os
primos que quer ser legal reclamou que
tem um rapaz no rosto da oua de pegar
uma senha de arroz votado nada botar o
saque de uva passa do outro senhor está
aqui gente é uma coisa que é uma pasta
que quem quiser me pega que mistura e
fome e deixa a boca eu sou bem pequena
queda em cada indicador pai do menino
dorme no cadúnico quer ver o papai noel
chegará lembro de quando descobrir que o
pai não existir eu estava tranqüilo
chega o papai noel em casa dissertar
desgraça o papai noel na praça do
palácio papai noel de andar na nossa
cola assim de meu deus vai tirar uma
bicicleta da sacola tinha um arco e
flecha estudou bem o que a crise é fazer
o quê nem norte e flecha que jack flash
que é paredes que vai puxar empregado na
paraíba na prega que é do paraguai foi
brincar que correm pela casa jogando
negócio quando penso que não entendendo
quarta meu time tirando a roupa de papai
noel de ti
o senhor é o papai noel eu tinha papai
noel notícia joelho e disse assim não
oito
o papai noel não existe
foi triste ele pra mim foi triste mas é
boa não acreditar em papai noel daqui um
dia pra frente é só acreditar em saci
pererê e 80 passou só vou decidir se
essa preciosa
se você gostou de civis já sabe fazer é
no mar seriam só clicar em gosto de aqui
no youtube
volta lá no facebook onde o vídeo nó qb
curtir no facebook marca seus amigos
também têm um natal estranho desse jeito
aqui e espero que o canal não depender
de um vídeo novo muito obrigado por este
vídeo até aqui é nóis alencar